if I were to buy a put option with a $50
exercise price and if I were to buy it
for $10 then the value of my position
the payoff for that put option at the
maturity or at the expiration I should
say at the expiration of the option
depending on what the stock price is
that expiration will look like this if
the stock price is worth if the stock
price goes to zero then the put option
is worth 50 because I could buy the
stock at zero and exercise my option to
sell at 50 at putting the the stock to
someone else at 50 dollars all the way
to the stock becomes worth 50 then my
put option I wouldn't need to exercise
it because why would I it's worthless to
have the option to sell something at 50
where you can just sell it in the sell
the actual stock in the open market or
buy the open or buy the stock at 50 so
then the put option becomes worthless
for a stock price above that now this is
the payoff diagram and this is when we
just think about the value at expiration
if we think about the actual profit and
loss at expiration it would look like
this it would just be shifted down by 10
dollars because we have to pay 10
dollars to get this value so if the
stock is worth zero the put option
itself is worth 50 but I have spent ten
dollars to get it so the profit is going
to be $40 and so then at 50
I wouldn't exercise the put option so
I've lost the ten dollars that I spent
on the option so my payoff diagram would
look like I want to draw it relatively
neatly my payoff diagram would look like
this once again this payoff diagram just
incorporates the price of the option so
it's the actual profit this is just the
value at expiration depending on what
the value of the stock is at expiration
now this is just a situation if you were
to buy an option but there has to be
someone on the other side of the
contract someone who's holding the
someone who's agreeing to buy the option
for you so you could actually have the
writer you could actually have the
writer of the put the payoff diagram we
just showed is the person who owns the
put but someone else had to have created
the put they said oh you know what I
will give you the right I will give you
the right to sell to sell me the stock
at 50
dollars up to some expiration date so
what does their payoff diagram look like
well if this guy is if this guy has is
going to be able to make $50 this guy's
over here the writer the writer of the
foot is going to lose $50 he's going to
have to essentially go out he's actually
going to have to buy that $50 put or buy
that $50 stock from this person because
he has to uphold his side of the
transaction but he's buying something
for $50 it's worthless because based
over at this end of the axis the stock
would be worth nothing so he's taking a
$50 loss all the way to him not having
to do anything because the foot holder
won't actually exercised their option of
death stock price is 50 so their payoff
diagram is going to look like this so
you can see it's actually the mirror
image of the payoff diagram of the
person on the other side of the contract
and if you were to add these two payoff
diagrams you would be neutral because
all of the money is exchanging hands
between the buyer and the seller of the
put if you look at the actual profit or
loss if the put is not exercised then
the writer of the foot essentially just
got a free $10 he sold he sold the put
to this guy for $10 she created the foot
and sold to that guy he gets $10 the
foots not exercised he gets to keep that
$10 but then if the stock goes down and
he's forced to buy the stock from the
owner of the foot he has to buy it
because that's his side of the deal that
all of a sudden he loses money so he
would go if all the way down if the
stock is worth nothing he is forced to
buy something for $50 it's worth nothing
he would take a $50 loss but he made the
$10 on the actual price of the of the
option so it would be a negative $40
profit and so his pay his profit and
loss would look like this but once again
these are the mirror images of each
other